[Music]
the olsen twins
you guys should start a clothing line
you'd be good
i can't believe i'm doing this um
bob saget was the biggest self-critic i
ever met
he questioned every choice
he thought about every project he did he
doubted himself in the darkest night
imagine his surprise as he looks down on
formidable industry insiders louding his
wealth of content creation in the world
of entertainment and non-fiction with
none other than a critic's choice real
tv impact award
now the funny thing about bob was that
he
he had the insecurity of the best
artists
everyone around him knew how funny he
was how side-splitting he was
just so brilliant and he was also
unparalleled
in his generosity
as a director producer actor stand-up
comedian and new york times best-selling
author
bob was successful in every medium of
media
he entered our hearts
as danny tanner on full house in fuller
house on netflix
before youtube he presented our biggest
pratt falls and most poignant moments
hosting america's funniest home videos
or
the original title america's funniest
nut shots
a lot of
colleagues including everyone at the
2018 impact awards
were charmed by his humor
his intelligence and his
open expression of love for family
friends
and his fans
known as a comedian's comedian he was
both a family funny guy
and an aristocrat of dirty jokes
the outpouring of tributes from the
filthiest comics to grandmothers in the
midwest showed just the range of
audience that he had adoring audience
personally
his legacy lives in my life
the guy taught me how to love deeply
fully allowing me to find such joy and
such gratitude in my marriage and my
fatherhood
tonight's critic choice real tv impact
honor only affirms what we all know
about bob saget's grace and his goodness
and even if we don't win one of these
cool awards
you know sometimes it's nice to silence
the critic within
and just believe everyone when they say
you are great
and you are amazing
and you are loved